Joe Biden walking back controversial
comments he made about undecided
african-american voters it came during
an interview with Breakfast Club
radio host Charlamagne tha God the
former vice president was touting his
record and support for the black
community when he said this we don't get
so much that's really our time I
apologize you can't do that the black
media you do that the white Manian block
maybe because my wife has to go on at 6
o'clock okay oh oh I'm in trouble
listen you got to come see us when you
come to New York VP Biden as well it's a
long way until November we got more
questions you got more questions without
telling if you have a problem figuring
out whether you're for mere Trump and
you ain't black they don't have nothing
to do with Trump it has to do with the
fact I want something for my community I
would love to see my record man I
extended the voting racks 25 years
and here's Biden responding to the
controversy a little bit later
take a listen never ever taken the
African desert community for granted had
their support over what we need as you
as going to tell you we have the eighth
largest african-american population of
the country the percent of population
it's what I've been involved with my
whole career and and so the last thing I
want to do and I should have been such a
wise guy I shouldn't offend so Cavalier
and responding to what I thought was
anyway it was I don't take it for
granted at all and no one no one should
vote for any party based on their race
or religion or background they're
african-american if you think Trump was
worth voting for I don't think so I'm
prepared what my record against is that
was the bottom line and it was it was
really unfortunate I shouldn't have been
so Cavalier
alright let's take it around the table
I'm Geraldo and initially one of his
senior advisors said that the Vice
President made the comment in jest and
then within the same news cycle the vice
president saying you should not have
been so cavalier
let's get your take on it well it it
reminded me he he reminded me of the
elderly lady in airplane in the scene
where you have two black guys who are
having a hard time because the airplane
is going through turbulence and they the
flight attendant can't communicate with
them then the little of a white lady
stands up and says I speak jive it was
like Biden said yeah I speak jive it was
really I didn't know where that where
that came from it seemed as awkward as
he can sometimes be I thought that was
really takes the cake I wonder if Katie
if gaps like that I don't even I was a
gap actually but you know comments like
that
could that be one of the reasons that
the the Democrats are not more bullish
about their chances going into November
despite some of the polls at recently
that looked good for Biden when he gets
out there you know we have a day like
this is not the best media cycle they've
had yeah I think that's absolutely
correct you know the more that he gets
into these situations where he has to
talk about what he's for and what he
plans to do he constantly just falls
back on his record rather than looking
at the future and providing a platform
for a modern era so he's still fighting
that but his comments came off as he you
know clearly described just now as
taking for granted the african-american
vote as Democrats have done for years
and it's really interesting to watch
this cultural shift that's been
happening in the past couple of years
under President Trump where you have
people like Kanye West and Sean Diddy
Combs coming out and saying look our
votes are not for free and we haven't
seen results from the people we've been
voting for in the Democratic Party for
decades now and we want to see some
change here so Joe Biden assumed based
on skin color that you should vote for a
certain party in a certain way which if
the shoe was on the other foot and a
Republican said this it would be
headline news on the front of every
single show
every single newspaper and every single
Republican would be asked about it but
instead Joe Biden will apologize for it
and the media will move on and I wonder
about that Greg because there are some
people that think well this won't matter
by dinnertime
and in that it does have a lot to do
with how the media reacts to something
like this yeah I have to say it for
original viewers of the five he pulled
it Beckel that's it when I when I lit
heard it I just made me think of it he
pulled it Beckel but here's the thing
okay
I thought his apology was pretty good
and when I watched this segment in
context I saw two people enjoying each
other's company and so he got a little
bit too comfortable but the point is my
opinion about his apology in my opinion
about the tape doesn't matter because
the opinion at the apology isn't for me
and I wouldn't be upset by what they did
but it's it's the black conservative
that is that it hurts right it's it's
not harmless and it's not funny to that
group because this is what is being said
about them you aren't black because you
voted for Reagan or bush or Trump it's
it's it this is not funny today like
Thomas soul or Larry elder or Lawrence
Jones or Candice Owen or Shelby Steele
or
Burgess oh and Charles Payne Walter
Williams
it's not funny to them because every
single day they okay I have a statement
from Robert Johnson who founded B et if
I could read that because that goes to
exactly what you're talking about Greg
it's he wrote this that the
vice-president Vice President Biden's
statement today represents the arrogant
and out of touch attitude of a
paternalistic white candidate who has
the audacity to tell black people the
descendants of slaves that they are not
black unless they vote for him this
proves unequivocally that the Democratic
nominee believes that black people owe
him their vote without question even
though we as black people know it is
exactly the opposite he should spend the
rest of his campaign apologizing
to every black person he meets Dan
Vaughn Gina
let's get your take on this because
there has been some comments that I saw
Juby for example his video that he put
out similar echoey in the comments that
Robert Johnson just put out as well yeah
you know I'm tired data of having to
take this fictitious high road you know
if we as conservatives and libertarians
if we come out and say listen we know
Joe Biden's not a racist and that's not
a racist comment and it was just a gaffe
that there's somehow the woke left is
going to extend the same courtesy to us
they won't they hate you the most people
on the Left not all Democrats but the
Liberals really do hate you
they think conservatives are really
awful people and don't care about your
ideas I'm done with that Joe Biden has a
history of stepping on his own tongue he
was the put y'all back in Chains guy you
can't go in a 7-eleven with